[Applause]
my first guess of course an actor and
Academy Award nominated director he can
now be seen in Clinton Clint Eastwood's
I have not slept in a couple of days
Clint Eastwood's Clint Eastwood's
critically acclaimed new film Mystic
River everybody's talking about this
movie please welcome Tim Robbins
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
right there this is so nice of you you
didn't have to do that gifts for Neve oh
that is so nice look at this she's gonna
love this
what are you thinking this drink baby
drink wow that's amazing you don't have
to do that that was very nice of you I
was just they just came out and said
Tim's here and he brought some stuff
which was yeah I think you should check
out Taylor the hug me turtle now look at
this
Taylor seems insane look at the back
right here it just says Taylor's just
one of those people you see on the
subway I'm in a world now of all this
crap I mean good I'm not putting
anything in my kid near that sea turtle
that turtles gone mad that's great
that's really okay that's that's crazy
and this is something that pops up and
frightens the child that's always nice
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah welcome to the world pal first you
like Gallagher here you have the problem
I got the joke with this - well that's
the Halloween outfit for her
number Gil oh that's so oh she puts this
on her head and then just bashes things
with this yeah I don't know much about
kids but I don't think you can give him
one of these and then this is playful
pages a toy that helps you learn when I
was a kid I hated any toy that helped me
learn this is it that's so cute a toy
from 1810 look at this here baby play
with this and we all out we won't
inoculate you like Wyatt book what does
that do oh man I feel like Kelly Ripa
out here Taylor yeah Europe Taylor I'm
Kelly Ripa together we're unstoppable
that's nice my quiet book okay that's
just weird that's that's for when the
baby discovers drugs
[Applause]
I think I think the turtle has been
staring at that for way too long Tommy -
Tommy - that's really nice I'm Robin
Williams I got a million of em cause bad
so let me ask you something that balloon
is making me crazy but I'll do it whoa
okay that's got to stop right now I just
wet myself you know I'm getting all
these baby and you have how many kids I
have three you have three kids there's
one thing that they have four kids that
we got that basically just it's a chair
and you put them in the chair and it
takes like three D batteries and you
push a button and the baby goes I don't
know what does that do is that calming
for the baby as opposed to Kabul oh okay
about that one I don't know about the
vibra bed like rocked like this but the
one trick I learned was taking him out
for a car ride is a good way to get him
to nap take him for a car ride really so
if the baby's a little tired take it to
the cars up to the parking garage in
Manhattan it's 15 blocks away strap it
in go down the FDR Drive look at ya cut
off a cab and send it into the river
yeah these are all great ideas yeah oh
if you let that go some Union guys gonna
have to get on a ladder and get it back
now let it go it's fine that's their
problem not our okay that's great that
will be terrific right here all right
there you go
that's terrific when we do our 20th
anniversary show there how am I feeling
I haven't slept and like I don't know so
long that I'm looking at for Tim Robbins
right now I'm deciding to talk to the
one that's second from the left but do
it because that's the most surprising
thing about that first year is the sleep
deprivation it's like definite yeah it's
like almost this crazy torture you know
just when you think you're going to
sleep the baby wake up
see that's not happening in my house man
I'm about Rule
yeah good luck I know explain to this
boy this two day old shot that's not
happening
[Music]
no it's and speaking III this is very
nice of you to first of all you were
supposed to be on the show yesterday and
I just was not I couldn't do it I was
too crazed trying to help my wife and
everything and they were very nice and
you said he just had his first kid I'll
come back tomorrow and do it which I
think was a very cool thing I was
supposed to be on the show and I had to
call at the last minute because I had
the coach playoff game game right and
you were very understanding about that I
said you'll never work again I said
you're going down Robins are going down
town